peu
m
[Musique]
le quartier général du führer communique
qu'après avoir à son poste de
commandement à la chance élevé luttez
jusqu'à son dernier souffle contre le
bolchévisme notre führer adolf hitler
est mort cet après-midi pour l'allemagne
du coup
l'homme le plus étonné d'europe le 30
avril 1945 en fin d'après-midi a
sûrement été le grand amiral carl zeiss
tout le monde c'était quoi connaissait
de nix chef de la kriegsmarine
[Musique]
organisateur de la guerre sous-marine
pendant laquelle il n'avait marqué des
succès incontestables
[Musique]
le
et il était là dans son quartier général
de la baltique à plein et devant lui l'
sur la table il y avait un télégramme ce
télégramme été signé norman le
collaborateur duclair et est ainsi
rédigé grand amiral de nice
le führer vous a désigné comme son
successeur quoi successeur rooney est un
ide se poser mille questions pourquoi
lui lui il n'avait jamais fait politique
mes successeurs d'hitler est ce que cela
voulait dire que hitler avait
l'intention de se donner la mort bientôt
le 30 avril 1945 les alliés ont envahi à
l'ouest et la plus grande partie de
l'allemagne sont sur l'elbe et au delà
et il les soviétiques qui sont dans
berlin qui occupent berlin
et
il n'y a plus de libre en allemagne qu
un étroit couloir entre les deux alliés
celui de l'est et de l'ouest
et ce couloir se rétrécit d'heure en
heure comme une peau de chagrin
alors oui l'avenir est perdu pour
l'allemagne nazie définitivement et
d'onyx le sait
[Musique]
alors si éclair l'a désignée pour être
son successeur c'est que isner va tirer
bientôt les conséquences de la situation
qu'il a refusé de voir en face
jusque là c'est qu hitler va donner la
mort la dernière fois qu'il l'a vu est
clair le grand amiral de nice
c'était le 21 avril il n'y avait eu neuf
jours de cela éclaire était depuis des
jours et des jours
réfugié dans son bunker de la
chancellerie du reich à berlin et de
nietzsche se souvenait d'avoir pénétré
dans les entrailles de la terre dure la
science elle rit dans la cour de la
chancellerie dans les jardins il y avait
tours de béton là un escalier qui
descend dréan et sendets longtemps
ce boom caire était recouvert par 15
mètres de béton et après avoir franchi
un premier bond girl veillée des
centaines de jeunes est-ce qu important
on descendait encore 37 marc fues et
l'on arrivait dans le führer ce bunker
le bunker d'hitler
c'est là que le 20 avril 1945 les
dignitaires nazis pour la dernière fois
c'était retrouver auprès de leur chef
goering était venu du sud où se trouvait
son quartier général
himmler étaient venues du nord et tous
ces hommes mettaient tout tony clair
pour lui célébré son anniversaire a tué
mon führer
je vous souhaite un heureux anniversaire
que ses hommes avec stups l on avait
entendu l'air alors que les soviétiques
et est aux portes de berlin déclaré
nous n'avons pas perdu la guerre berlin
sera un piège pour les soviétiques je
gagnerai la bataille de berlin et göring
était reparti vers le sud est où l'air
était reparti vers le nord et green dans
le sud s'étaient empressés de traiter
avec les américains et himmler dans le
nord s'était empressé de traiter avec
les alliés par l'intermédiaire du comte
bernadotte un suédois de nix avait pris
congé
deux éclairs le 21 et il se souvenait de
l'homme qui l'avait vu de ce fantôme des
dictateurs quand on se souvenait des
grands discours à nuremberg mais il n'y
avait pas un siècle de smiley vais
seulement quelques années ces foules
immenses ces étendards à croix gammée
[Musique]
et l'homme qui hurlait sa foi dans la
victoire du nazisme et quand on me
voyait là dans un tout traînant ses
pieds comme un grand malade qu'il était
devenu
et surtout ce bras droit donc il n'était
pas maître est toute récente et à chaque
instant maladie de parkinson
c'est cette image qui dominait et
pourtant quand des nits étaient partis
vers lui avait dit nous gagnerons la
guerre danic et donne et c'était reparti
vers le nord la sur la baltique à plein
son quartier général
[Musique]
et ça mais lui il avait vu le désastre
était partout de l'armée allemande ou
puissant qu'il n'existait que des débris
exemple les bleus délavés plus d'essence
les soldats s'étaient des gosses de 15
ans des vieux de 60 ans et il n'avait
plus de pales pour leur fusil
[Musique]
il y avait eu deux millions de morts
militaires et combien de milliers de
centaines de milliers de morts civils
[Musique]
et là maintenant à plein sur son bureau
ce télégramme le führer vous a désigné
pour son successeur
mais comment cela était il arrivé
ce n'est que le 28 avril parce que les
soviétiques était maintenant temps
berlin à quelques centaines de mètres du
bunker comme claire des consenti à
reconnaître que tout était prêt à sortir
et russe a détruit notre dernier terrain
d'envol
où est l'armée de 25 20 combats dans la
région de potsdam
il ne peut se frayer un chemin vers
berlin mais c'est tout c'est tout mon
frère dans la nuit du 28 au 29 il
épouser sa compagne de plusieurs années
et fabre
après qu il dicte son testament et ce
testament commence ainsi venait pas
voulu la guerre ce qui me l'ont imposé
sont des politiciens de race juive et
cela continue longtemps longtemps
cinq années ont passé n'a encore rien
compris rien appris rien oublié et dans
ce testament justement il désigne des
knicks pour son successeur
ainsi que goebbels
l'ancien ministre de l'information qui
sera chancelier du raje martin bormann
la sinistre éminence brune qui sera
ministre du parti et sizing quartz qui
sera ministre des affaires étrangères
voilà ce qu'il y a dans ce testament le
hitler a annoncé que c'était ce jour là
qu'il se donnerait la mort il faut dire
qu'il était temps les soviétiques
étaient à 3 ou 400 mètres du bourguet
en
à 15h30 il s'est retiré dans son
appartement avec eva brand
en
et quand son valet de chambre un peu
plus tard est entré une à trouver de
cada celui d'hitler celui de sa compagne
comme l'avait ordonné y tenait on a
tenté de brûlé avec de l'essence
ces deux cadavres dans le jardin de la
chancellerie
on y est parvenu que très mal avec 180
litres d'essence on ne brûle pas de
cadavre on les a enterrés ces restes
calcinés mes attaques dans un trou
d'obus
cela avait pris beaucoup de temps il
était 6 heures et demie du soir il y
avait comme un climat de soleil dans le
bunker
[Musique]
la ventilation ne fonctionnait plus et
des témoins ont dit qu'il y avait comme
un air moisi un air de morts que l'on
respiré et c'est que bell ce qui a
essayé de mettre un peu d'ordre là
dedans et qui avec boorman a décidé
d'expédier le télégramme adonix qui lui
apprenait qu'il était le successeur vie
claire mais choses extraordinaires
on n'a pas dit adonix que hitler était
mort dans la nuit
bormann n'est que de belles sont essayés
des chapeaux des le plan de la dernière
chance dans le bunker il y amène en
général le général creps il avait été
attaché militaire adjoint à moscou
autrefois et il répétait volontiers peu
staline l'aimé bien et que même un jour
sur le quai de la gare à moscou staline
lui avait donné l'accolade et boorman et
goebel se sont dit mais nous tenons
l'homme nous allons envoyer creps
négocier avec les russes depuis 1943 les
alliés n'avaient cessé de proclamer
qu'ils ne négocieraient jamais ni avec
hitler ni avec aucun nazis et pourtant
creps était sorti là dans la nuit
s'était présentée aux soviétiques
avaient été conduits au général
tchouikov qui commandait l'unité chargée
de prendre le bunker il rapatrie creps
chef pascal reich par vestas paccione
chef de quartier général de l'armée
allemande général creps et nous
connaissons même le dialogue creps plein
de superbe s'adresse à tchoyi 4 comme la
journée du 1er mai commencé et légumes
belle journée général
belle journée pour nous deux
elle tricote fait un et qui dit eh oui
général belle journée pour nous pour
vous c'est pas sûr et creps essayent
d'obtenir des sauf conduits pour boorman
à goebbels
car c'est ça leur jeu ils voudraient des
sauf conduits pour pouvoir rejoindre de
knicks dans le nord de l'allemagne et
prendre leur place dans le nouveau
gouvernement
nous sommes dans la réalité la plus
totale et comme compensation boorman et
goebbels offre berlin aux soviétiques
mais racing éthiques ont déjà vers l'est
alors que le kof répondra non la
retraite ne sommes pas d'accord pas
d'armistice il soit de 24 heures ou
d'une ère mais creps plaide et ça dure
des heures et il reviendra au vainqueur
et boorman à l'eau sept heures du matin
le 1er mai décide d'envoyer un nouveau
télégramme à de nietzsche et des knicks
des cours le nouveau télégramme de
boorman selon lequel le testament entre
en vigueur
s'il entre en vigueur s'éclairer mort et
pourtant boorman n'a pas spécifié
expressément qu'il père était mort mais
le testament entre en vigueur
nous sommes encore dans l'absurdité la
plus totale et quand creps rien à la fin
de la matinée pour dire il n'y a aucun
espoir de belz prend sa décision
et l'après-midi s'avançant on décide
d'envoyer un troisième télégramme adonix
cette fois ci on va tout lui dire le
führer emma vous êtes sans successeur
goebel c'est son chancelier etc et
boorman annonce je vais tenter de vous
rejoindre
madame bel va écrire à son fils aîné qui
heureusement pour lui n'est pas dans le
bouquet le führer est mort la vie ne
vaut plus la peine d'être vécue
[Musique]
imperturbable et du paquebot n'a pas
encore la fin d'après midi
[Musique]
goebel c'est sa femme du leurs six
enfants
si les petits ne se rend compte de rien
les nez elle comprend et allure
je ne veux pas mourir elle nature après
quoi elles sortent dans l'escalier du
brome caire dehors et la de ss sur leur
ordre les abattent une balle dans la
nuque
[Musique]
on tentera de brunet aussi leur cada
ils ont admis qu'ils suivent bormann
vous savez comme les rares équipes les
navires normal s'enfuir à déboguer au
lieu de se donner la mort ce qui aurait
été peut-être considéré de sa part comme
le seul geste honorable qu'il ait jamais
accomplie et s'enfuit par les tunnels du
métro on ne le reverra jamais
le 1er mai au soir qu'il avait fallu que
de nice se décide à annoncer au peuple
allemand est claire et est mort et il
était 22h30 sur les antennes de radio
hambourg lorsque l'on avait interrompu
les émissions en cours et un speaker
avait annoncé ne quittez pas l'écoutent
dans quelques instants sera diffusé une
nouvelle de la plus grande importance
alors on avait fait entendre
du wagner il semblait fatale que wagner
fut présent et puis quelques mesures de
la septième symphonie de bruckner et
ensuite le speaker avait déclaré
un führer et marc lesueur est mort à la
tête de son armée dans berlin
au cours du dernier combat contre le
bolchevisme
ce n'était pas vrai mais de nice
à ce moment précis ignorer les
circonstances de la mort d'hitler il
pensait sincèrement il perd étaient
morts dans un bombardement et ces de
nice qui en gêner et femmes d'allemagne
et un soldat de la wehrmacht notre
führer adolf hitler est mort et qui a
annoncé qu'il prenait la succession
d'hitler pour poursuivre la guerre et
l'exhorté toutes mes forces et allemands
à se battre à se battre à se marier
alors qu'est ce que voulait dire demix
alors qu'il savait pertinemment et il
l'avait répété à tout ce qui l'entouré
que la guerre était nuit tout simplement
donné de jouer le rôle logique d'un
politicien conséquent d'un homme d'état
conséquent s'il annoncé qu'il allait
ouvrir des négociations immédiatement
les troupes de l'allemande
ce serait le combat un peu partout là où
elle se trouvait mais dans le plus grand
désordre et on avoue qu eje au chaos
[Musique]
justement pour pouvoir solliciter une
interruption d'armes il fallait se
battre que soldat allemand jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
et le lendemain de même une nouvelle des
venues rejoindre de nit l'armée
allemande d'italie commandé par le
maréchal kesselring venez de capitule
[Musique]
décidément il ne restait rien du système
de défense allemande
ce système s'effondre et partout bleus
étaient menacés les anglais les
américains foncé vers la baltique il a
fallu partie partir vers plein ce
bouquin port de la baltique
quel à s'installer sur un bateau passe
est normal pour un bateau qui s'appelait
le patriat et de nice ne s'installe et
pas sur le patriat seul un homme la
compagnie le 21 avril plusieurs
ministres de heatley avait quitté berlin
pour se rendre dans le nord il y avait
notamment ribbentrop le trop fameux
ministre des affaires étrangères mais il
y avait aussi schwerin von krause et le
ministre des finances il l'était avant
qu'hitler arrive au pouvoir
c'était un technicien est clair l'avait
gardé ce n'était pas un nazi ce n'était
pas non plus un opposant farouche
c'était un homme qui avait fait son
métier mais parmi ces fanatiques et
quelquefois c'est demi fous j'suis une
funk rozic vous pouvez passer pour un
homme raisonnable et c'est pourquoi des
nits qui savait qu'il ne pourrait
exercer ses fonctions seuls qu'ils
avaient besoin au moins d'un conseiller
l'avait sollicité voulez-vous être le
chancelier de mon nouveau gouvernement
n'ont pas chancelier à mehdi je suis
arrivé on croisait pas de titre à
l'époque où nous sommes au moment où
nous sommes réunis sont un gouvernement
de techniciens
et si vous voulez je serai le ministre
directeur est désormais là flensbourg
tous les jours à 10h du matin dans une
école autour d'une table pinte est assis
sur des chaises dépareillées des nits
réunira ses ministres parmi ceux ci il y
avait je perds le ministre de l'armement
qui avait accepté et aussi et à la
première réunion affrontements immédiat
il y avait les militaires le maréchal a
été long le général jodl et eux ne
voulaient pas entendre parler de
capitulation parce que le mot
capitulation est un mot qui est reçu
comme une humiliation sans nom 20
militait dans les premiers cours que
l'on enseigne dans les écoles militaires
on apprend à refuser le mot capitulation
alors il ne voulait pas de capitulation
ces deux militaires disent eh bien oui
de ici et là chaque corps se rendent
quand il sera vraiment au bout de ses
forces
il n'y aura pas de reddition général des
redditions séparés et il avait fallu peu
cher et une faune creuser que je perds
répondent avec autant de violence en
disant mais enfin vous ne pensez pas aux
bombardements
qui accable toutes les villes
d'allemagne il y est en ce moment même à
chaque heure des milliers de morts
innocents
est-ce que vous pensez que il n'y a plus
de carburant nulle part que le
ravitaillement ne passe plus est ce que
vous pensez qu'il n'y a plus de charbon
que pour 10 jours de la plupart des
villes n'ont plus d'électricité n'ont
plus rien est ce que vous pensez à cela
et vous voulez que des corps d'armée se
bat peut être encore pendant un mois
pendant 2 mois que l'on continue ce
massacre inutile et de niels avait été
convaincu et avait dit eh bien oui nous
avons négocié alors négocier il savait
bien des nits ce qu'avaient déclaré les
alliés pas de négociation nous ne
recevront qu'une demande de capitulation
totale
mais oui mais est-ce que même en
demandant à capituler on ne pouvait pas
discuter obtenir quelque chose
ses clientes et demi
et on peut le comprendre c'est sûr
reflux massif des populations allemand
l'est qui devant l'arrivée des
soviétiques s'enfuyaient vers l'ouest
c'était des scènes que nous avons connus
noir 1940 des scènes accablant de
vieillards de femmes d'enfants qui
marchaient sur les routes très nom ou
cent des véhicules hétéroclite une fille
elle avance de société qu'il faut dire
que les allemands s'étaient livrés à de
telles exactions en russie on écrème il
y avait tant de meurtre massacres de
viols que les russes qui arrivent et ne
demandait qu'à se venger et ces
allemands russes avaient alors ils
fuient c'était affreux parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'innocents parmi ceux
qui font de nice vous savez mais nice ne
penser qu'à cela
alors comment obtenir que protégé par
l'armée allemande qui retardaient le
plus possible à l'est la vence des
soviétiques
comment obtenir que ces réfugiés
puissent aller au moins jusqu'à la ligne
de démarcation prévu par les alliés
on savait que là les russes s'arrêterait
ça allait aller jusque là
alors pour envoyer un négociateur aux
alliés des nits n'avait pas trop
confiance en kite et les young
parce que il n'est avait vu quelque
temps plus tôt quelques instants plus
tôt avoir des raisonnements de jusqu'au
boutisme
il a choisi un marat comme les halles
homme qu'il connaissait bien la mayral
phone friedberg et le 3 mai lan erhalten
freedom s'est mis en rogne pour le
quartier général de mon come on était
tout près mon grand morié vous ai dit
que tout cela s'était réduit à presque
rien et femmes friedberg était arrivé
sur cette lande à lüneburg ou montgomery
avait établi son quartier général
et il y avait là sur cette langue des
tentes des bâtiments provisoires et puis
une caravane c'était la demeure de
montgomery elle le suivait depuis des
années il n'y était habitué il y était
bien et voilà devant cette caravane
l'amiral phone frimpong les deux
officiers qui l'accompagnent et
montgomery qui ouvre la porte de la
caravane et qu'ils les voient il est là
dans son battle grèce habituel avec son
béret célèbre et il lance mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ces gens là et qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent freebox avant il déclare
il est venu pour capture
alors s'engage une conversation très dur
pour les allemands difficile pour mon
roman parce que les points de vue sont
totalement opposés et fribourg déclare
qu'il veut capitulé pour les armées
allemandes du 9 mai qu'il veut que les
armées allemandes du nord qui lutte
contre les soviétiques capitule entre
les mains de montgomery et c'est bien
pourquoi et mogwai
c'est bien pourquoi également est mort
gomery d'éclat en ce qui concerne les
armes écrit son talent est il faut
quelques habitudes entre les mains des
russes et fribourg qui dit nous ne
voulons pas capituler entre les mains de
ces sauvages de russes et montgomery lui
répond sauvage est ce que vous ne croyez
pas que vous auriez pu y penser en 1941
alors on discute fric bo tente de gagner
du temps et il parle des réfugiés un
mauvais mot une en parle ouvertement
[Musique]
j'ai jugé que des bateaux vont chercher
maintenant ce bateau allemand
à l'est on est ramené au danemark je ne
sais pas un monument aux morts et le 4
mai au matin voilà que le conseil des
ministres de denis tu serais nouveau l
amiral phone friborg est de retour et il
est là qu parents devant des mythes et
les autres qui parlent d'une
capitulation totale et simultanée au
gomery exige non seulement la
capitulation du schleswig holstein
mais aussi de la hollande qui est
toujours occupée par l'allemagne du
danemark est toujours occupée et puis
aussi de la frise des îles et frisonne
david holland de tout cela et à la table
là dans cette petite école de flensbourg
plusieurs déclare mais c'est impossible
parce que si la capitulation et général
et bien les bateaux ne pourra plus aller
chercher des réfugiés et si nous rendons
danemark ne pourront plus conduire les
réfugiés au danemark est alors l'amiral
red bull répond le maréchal montgomery
m'a laissé entendre que même après la
capitulation
le mouvement des transports pourrait se
poursuivre
alors la sadc
les amis de 2 mx on donne le feu vert
l'amiral qui rebat et voilà de nouveau
la lande de lunebourg et bleu et il y a
là des journalistes qui justement
s'abrite de la vue y est voilà qui doit
paraître montgomery cette fois il a dû
faible cote en poil de chameau avec un
capuchon
il a l'air très content un jovial leur
grève et voilà ça va se terminer
j'attendais le maréchal bluetec il dit
d'ailleurs monsieur biométrique qui ont
la passion
alors j'ai vu un amiral et justement net
de commandes mari ont déjà un scénario
bien réglée apparaît en dix ans l'amiral
fouad primordial robert biever des
mangues en jeu voilà qui sort pour
gagner sa caravane
il pleut beaucoup et là devant la
caravane lui à l'amiral avec quatre
autres officiellement stoïques sous la
boue et montgomery passe sans arguent
ils entrent dans sa caravane ils
laissent la porte d'à les autres sont
toujours sur la plaie et lamerat iphone
freebox et perçoit alors que mongongu
est en train de lire le journal
pas tout à fait par hasard s'il laisse
les allemands sous la plaie
puis montgomery nouveau demande afrique
bang est ce que vous avez l'autorisation
de capituler je les ai pris un bon venez
avec moi et free bogey conduit dans une
autre temps qui avait été préparé pour
la circonstance
et c'est là qu'il va signer avec
montgomery nhs la capitulation de toutes
les forces allemandes des normes légales
la délégation allemande va maintenant
signé ce document
ses membres
sinon dans l'ordre de leurs grades
général admiral friburg signera en
premier
mais
ensuite le général keen sol
[Rires]
sané et je signerais moi même ou non vus
commandant suprême des alliés le général
al janna
[Musique]
alors oui en photo ap quatre contre
trois pour ces cas là tu es mauvais
maureen toujours jovial lui disant ya
l'union jack
ce matelas est-ce que vous pouvez nous
prendre avec lui en jack le photographe
dit oui monsieur majak allégi et bien
voilà une photo historique
[Rires]
le
lui
le généralissime à noël commandant
suprême de toutes les forces alliées
l'ouest installé quelques jours plus tôt
104 et générale à reims
[Musique]
et il attend c'est que la capitulation
et enfin de signer et normalement il
devrait déjà avoir eu un coup de fil
montgomery depuis un certain temps rien
du tout et il n'est pas trop patient le
général eisenhower puisque neal bear sas
cathay qu'est qui attendit n'était pas
seulement de secrétaire en tout cas elle
était charmant et lui dis moi j'en ai
assez je m'en vais rentrer chez vous est
ce que lui disent les attendait au moins
cinq minutes cinq minutes pas une de
plus hélas l'oeil sur sa montre cinq
minutes se passe il va partir le
téléphone et ses mangas etc et lui
annonce la capitulation et si bien c'est
très bien mentez et eisel ils ont des
pseudonymes
les grands chefs militaires modibo
montgomery ike eisenhower et bien
démenti demain l'amiral von fritsch beau
viendra signer la capitulation générale
sur tous les fronts est ce que vous le
verrez je crois pas d eisenhower qu'il
signe et quand il aura signé je le
verrai alors
la première partie est faite le second
acte est pour bientôt
le 5 mai 1945 à 17h ainsi qu'il était
prévu voilà l'amiral fabricants
[Musique]
dans cette école professionnelle dans
ces collèges techniques de garçons où il
croit qu'il va rencontrer un énorme et
il ne rencontre que le général medel
smith militaires américains de haut rang
bien sûr mais ça n'est pas aisé noël
alors il espère encore pouvoir discuter
d'une capitulation séparés à l'est ou à
l'ouest erreur totale il le comprend
dans l'instant il ya les ordres les
alliés ont signé des accords et staline
roosevelt et churchill et on sait à
l'avancé que le jour de la capitulation
générale
eh bien elle devra s'exercer sur
l'ensemble de tous les
alors frébault sans qu'il ne brûlera pas
ce rock et il se trouve peut-être
sûrement au moment le plus grave le plus
décisif de sa vie parce que comme tmx
inc hanté par l'image des réfugiés qui
fait comment faire
n'obtiendra rien en ce qui concerne la
capitulation
au moins ils essayent de gagner du temps
parce que chaque jour et même chaque
heure qui passe permet à quelques
milliers de réfugiés de passer la
fameuse ligne de démarcation
[Musique]
alors il déclare qu'il n'a pas de
pouvoir enseigner comment il pourrait
bien signer mais il est dans son rôle je
n'ai pas de pouvoir jeu je suis envoyé
ici uniquement pour conduire des
pourparlers pour que je signe la
capitulation il faudrait que j'aie
l'autorisation de mon chef du grand
amiral dennis très bien demander là a
dit mais dès le 6 rapp des frais de bol
d'où une admirable comédie je m'aperçois
que je n'ai pas emporter le code code ah
oui je ne peux pas lui envoyer le
message puisque je n'ai pas le code et
bien envoyé les en clair on veut message
au point vous en êtes qu'est ce que
c'est important au du fric mais je n'ai
pas non plus la longueur d'onde ou n'est
pas la fréquence et puis je vous
préviens que pour avertir tous les corps
nous avons encore en europe et qui
combattent
il ya plus de communication c'est le
désordre le plus complet il faudrait au
moins 48 1 oui
smith chacun joue sa comédie vous avez
dans cette affaire la sarre et souvent
dans ce genre de réunion
dell smith possède sur son bureau une
grande carte des opérations avec des
flèches qui convergent toutes vers le
centre de l'allemagne vers la baltique
pour faire bonne mesure mais de la spesa
même fêtera ses deux flèches imaginait
alors ' il pousse délicatement la carte
vers l'amiral qui se penchent pour la
regarder cet accablant accablant et nous
savons que quand la mayral a relevé m
il y avait des larmes qui coulaient sur
son examen le lendemain 6 mai à 9 heures
du matin
toujours dans cette école de flensburg
l'impression que toute cette histoire se
passe dans des écoles des knicks
réunissant google et là on va entendre
le général keen zèle le général keen
zèle qui était avec fribourg grâce et
que free debout qu'à envoyer parce que
on s'expliquera mieux verbalement que
par des messages ekin celle là raconte
ce que exige exonère pas de capitulation
séparer capitulation générale les forces
allemandes qui reste en place
à l'instant même de la capitulation et
alors la yole éclate il c'est impossible
et enfin vous vous rendez compte que
vous allez fixé sur place nos forces à
l'est que vous avez en faisant cela pris
la décision de livrer les réfugiés au
récit et par ailleurs nous ne pourrons
pas l'obtenir parce que jamais un corps
d'armée jamais une division jamais un
régime on ne s'arrêtera sur place il y
aura tout de suite violation de l'accord
il plaide bien violent
il plaide tellement bien que de mitsou
leur garde des deals général vous allez
partir porras quoi moi par pierre potvin
oui vous allez renforcer la mission de
l'amiral une frite borg
vous allez aller à venir cela parisienne
rêve
terry young est d'accord et young bas
le même jour 6 mai un homme se présente
chez le ministre directeur fait une
feinte de croisée que c'est un crime
lèse vous savez le fidèle à une riche
comme l'appelait et il a perdu de sa
faconde et il a perdu toute sa mort me
müller lui qui était si sûr de lui
lui qui croyait que les américains les
anglais ferait appel à lui il n'ya plus
que de la terreur dans les yeux
l'immeuble est lui qui a conduit à la
terreur tant de millions de gens et le
demande à schwerin femmes creuser
monsieur le ministre directeur
il est plein d'humilité tout à coup
que vais-je devenir moi j'espérais une
forme chronique qui est plate et qui dit
ça n'est pas mon affaire
est ce que vous croyez que je me
préoccupe de ce que je vais devenir moi
ici on ne se préoccupe que de
l'allemagne alors arrangez vous faites
ce que vous voulez si j'ai un conseil à
vous donner
mais vous ne le suivrait pas allez vous
rendre au maréchal montgomery et puis je
m'appelle heinrich himmler c'est moi qui
a régné sur les camps de concentration
c'est moi qui ai tué les juifs les
tziganes les polonais et les ukrainiens
allé lui dire ça à montgomery
[Musique]
est allé lui dire je me rends pour
prendre sur moi tous ces crimes de mes
subordonnés ont été exécutés sur maison
[Musique]
ne vous ne ferez pas mais ba se rend
chez lui va raser sa dérisoire petite
moustache va mettre ses l'ornement dans
un tiroir et va secourir un oeil d'un
bandeau noir et il va se perdre dans un
maquis ont ils besoin et deux semaines
plus tard les anglais l'arrêterons il
subira un examen médical de routine car
les alliés savent très bien que tous ces
navires possède sur une capsule de
cyanure
mais cependant que le médecin allait
mettre la main dans sa bouche pour lui
retirer la capsule éventuelles il a
croqué dans la capsule
immédiatement il est mort
mais le général l'yonne est arrivé lui a
ravi il a rejoint phryne bourghelles se
sont retrouvés tous les deux en présence
de beatles mais ces deux strophes du
général stores et young l'un géré au
mieux appliquées oui nous allons
capituler la capitulation générale des
prises en cause nous vous demandons 48
heures pour les réfugiés alors que 30
des convaincus par yom elle va voir les
annuaires et lui dit accorder leur ca et
ancien maire répond non parce qu'il y a
des ordres éternellement ses ordres
signé par les trois grands il est là
pour appliquer les ordres
donc c'est non et pourtant quand ils
fixent la date la capitulation
eisenhower déclare ce sera
le 9 mai
à 0
il les a et ongles ses 48 heures et au
delà
alors une tire immédiatement les
conséquences de tout cela et télégraphie
à 2 need accepté nouvelle réunion à
flensbourg du gouvernement des knicks et
profonde perplexité toujours autour de
ce mot humiliant déshonorant pour
certains militaires de capitulation et
on les écoute il faut franchir le pas il
faut franchir le rubicon est ce qu'on va
le faire et on discute encore longuement
longuement jusqu'au moment où on reçoit
un nouveau message de iob et exige
réponse immédiate
alors là on comprend que il n'est pas
possible de remettre éternellement la
réponse c'est dan its envoie un
télégramme période
accepter il est 2h41 des matins le 7 mai
1945 quand et arguent les frites borg se
trouve dans cette grande salle où les
élèves du collège technique jouer encore
quelques semaines plus tôt ou une fois
[Musique]
m
et il y à la 17 correspondre à une
guerre triés sur le volet il n'ya là et
photographe il n'ya là les cameramans d
actualité il ya là un général soviétique
général sociaux par of général amériques
gamme général par d'autres militaires de
tout grade
peter smith bien sûr estran et c'est là
que guillaume et fric bob bon signe
[Musique]
la capitulation allemande et c'est alors
seulement on les conduit dans le bureau
daiza noël qui les attend qu'ils vont
entrer les regards et horde les frites
bob de s'approche claque des talons
devant ike salut et avec une certaine
dureté qui frappent qu'est sa secrétaire
eisenhower demande avez vous bien
compris les termes de la capitulation
que vous avez signé ya ya un podium est
bien certain nombre de précisions vous
sont transmises d'ultérieures mans vous
prenez l'engagement de les faire
connaître à votre eau et a fait encore
violent c'est terminé
les deux allemands ont sacré salure
fonds de métaux le 7 mai à 10h55 de nice
est en possession du texte intégral de
la capitulation
que peut-il faire sinon s'incliner alors
il transmet comme et s'y est engagé le
texan à toutes les forces armées
allemandes en l'europe et même très loin
dans le monde il y a des bateaux
allemands et des sous marins allemands
tout le monde sait qu'une oie
[Musique]
12h45 c'est le ministre directeur
schwerin funk rozic qui prend la parole
à la radio et qui annonce à tous les
allemands qui peuvent l'entente sont ils
nombreux il ya si peu d'électricité en
allemagne à ce moment là il n'ya pas
triste mais il parle et une annonce la
fin des combats
[Musique]
cependant alors que tout à l'air de se
passer
admirablement voilà que quelqu'un se
montre offensif
c'est à moscou le généralissime stagne
parce que le généralissime dali de toute
éternité avait décidé que quand on
n'enregistre ray la capitulation
allemande ce serait à berlin et pourquoi
a t'on signe arras évidemment il y avait
un officier général russe qui étaient là
bas qui avaient signé mais enfin ça ne
suffit pas à steam et les messages
portent à l'adresse des nerfs il faut
faire une nouvelle signature à bien et
un jeune aux mondiaux qui n'est pas
contre pourquoi causer du déplaisir à
staline né à ses camarades russe et son
camarade de combat est originaire envoie
un message je suis d'accord et j'irai
demain à berlin signé une nouvelle fois
la capitulation
alors maintenant demain nous sommes le 8
mai 1945 et à 10 heures du matin sur
l'aérodrome de tempelhof à berlin le
maréchal sokolowski et là qui attend les
à noël
voilà un avion américain qui atterrit
m
alors que ce projet qui court pour
accueillir un musée n'aurait pas du tout
ça n'est pas le noir c'est le maréchal
britannique des nerfs qui disent très
souriant figuil général jean noël n'a
pas pu venir et c'est moi qui le
représente qu'est ce qui s'est passé oui
à l inverse avait dans un premier
mouvement
le câble et qui n'arrivait est puissant
et à valeur vous savez il ya toujours
des gens pointilleux dans les
états-majors de tous les pays d'ailleurs
sans l'état major lui avait dit
attention c'est le maréchal joukov qui
va signer à berlin pour les russes il
n'est que commandant d'un groupe
d'armées vous vous êtes généralissime
vous ne pouvez pas mettre votre
signature à côté de la sienne se fait à
tenter à votre prestige personnel la
gamme ans il n'est que commandants de
groupes d'armées via un passionné
j'envoie tedder ce sera bien évidemment
il joue comme ça tant des murs n'avait
même réparer toutes sortes de gâteries
d'une champagne du caviar des petits
gâteaux et ou à venir que td ans plus
tôt ne voit pas venir parce qu'il est
fou de rage et dit je ne veux pas le
voir tout ça était complètement enfanta
quand on pense qu'il ya encore des gens
qui meurent à cet angle là puisque la
captive à sion n'est que pour le soir à
minuit et tous ses états majors qui se
font des échanges de susceptibilité
cette étrange savez vous combien de
temps joue comme va faire vers
antichambre athenes 5
enfin bull cinq heures ils rejoignent
donc pas là dessus
nous allons signer ce soir tout va bien
un autre général américain est arrivé ce
patch qui déclare qu'il veut signer
aussi parce que tu es des angles à mort
pourquoi pas
alors lemarchal kate elle se rend à
berlin par avion et atterri à tempérer
[Musique]
oh
une relève qui attend
et puis voilà encore un autre général et
arrive et 7,1 france c'est le général de
lattre de tassigny
il est accompagné de deux officiers le
colonel de metz et le capitaine bandeau
et la veille le général de gaulle
l'amendé lui a dit delattre nous ne
sommes pas invités à berlin
c'est bien pourquoi je vous y envoie
tout à fait légaux alors delattre sait
très bien ce qu'il a à faire une haie
pas invité mais il faut tout simple et
au coffre qu'ils vont signer à fait
d'accord tout va bien lorsque arrive de
moscou vit chinsky l'un des maîtres de
la diplomatie soviétique qui lui n'est
plus d'accord du tout il veut bien que
le français de la piscine
ce sera un symbole de la résurrection de
la france mais ne veut pas que
l'américain spa ti et pourquoi est-ce
que je ne signerai pas dix pattes
ben vous l'avez pas à signer puisque le
maréchal britannique cédait représente
le général eisenhower ressource présente
par conséquent l'ensemble des anglais
des américains
alors on discute à perte de vue cette
dure un temps fou et on trouve une
transaction
joe cole et eider signeront au bas de
l'acte et pâtes et de l'ap en dessous
bon et c'est ce qu'on va tous vous
sachiez que dans le cours de l'après
midi et bien le colonel de med s'est mis
en quatre pour pouvoir prouver un
drapeau français y avaient pas besoin
pas besoin de vous dire qu'à kallstrom
bernoise d'époque n'avait pas de
passeport français
alors il a fallu le faire confectionner
par les petites secrétaire soviétique
puis ont pris les aiguilles
ils se sont mis à coudre les je pense
qu'elle que quelques étoffe bleu blanc
rouge et qu'elle avait d'abord à cause
du reste dans le sens horizontal est
trop fort en ce vertical si bien
dans un premier temps s'étonnera
broualan bay qui a été mis à la place du
drapeau français
donc ça a été réparé et 4 sommes entrés
dans la salle le soir le drapeau
français et est au centre et née germans
inclinés par rapport aux trois autres
épices se trouvait derrière
oh
[Musique]
et voici leur arrivée
dans cette salle bourrée de journalistes
de photographes d'appareils de cinéma
avec des projecteurs pour éclairer tout
cela car on veut enregistrer cela pour
l'avenir on n'ose prédire pour
l'éternité
et voici que sont derrière leur table
tous les officiers généraux qui vont
signer
[Musique]
son arrivée quétel j'étais très proche
de lui puisque j'étais à la table
perpendiculaire à la table de signature
mais tout près de l'entrée
keitel a salué ce matin maréchal
l'assistance ils doivent est resté
impassible est ainsi et kate elle a
laissé tomber son bâton de maréchal avec
un mouvement est ainsi de très grands
moments
les trois plénipotentiaires allemands se
sont assis et alors
joukov sainement et à poser les
questions s'est adressé à kate elle en
lui disant avez-vous les pouvoirs
nécessaires pour représenter votre pays
le troisième reich etes-vous mandaté
pour la signature et alors vous allez
assister à la revente
nick et elle y va rester assis pour vol
et qui va diriger des poumons et c'est
ainsi que successivement kate elle
d'abord s'est levé et est passé derrière
moi pour aller signer au bout de la
table de signature exactement à côté du
général de la sete
lorsqu'il est passé derrière moi on se
rendre sa foi à côté de là j'ai entendu
qu'ils grand moule est une phrase
qu'elle y avait 30 chez eux et je me
suis tourné vers l'interprète qui se
trouvait à proximité de moi je dis
qu'est ce qui vient d et c'est ainsi que
j'ai su qu'il avait dit qu à côté d'un
français c'est un comble alors est ce
que il a dit les français ici une
moquette mixa à côté d'un français c'est
un compte
je ne vous dirai pas aujourd'hui la
traduction exacte toujours été que c'est
ce qu'il a prononcé son führer d'être
assis à côté la face
il va signer
[Musique]
et cette fois c'en est bien fini et à 0
heures comme prévu dans toute l'europe
les canons cesse d'étonner les avions on
n'en voit plus de bombes
les soldats ne tirent plus haut des
millions et des millions de gens c'est
une lumière nouvelle qui va se lever
lumière que l'on avait oublié que l'on
croyait ne plus jamais revoir la lumière
de la paix alors certes il annonce la
bonne nouvelle là pour le britannique
n'est pas si flegmatique on le dit bien
de crier sa joie
à new york en tous cas semaine les
redmen partout à travers le monde
[Musique]
à paris président des amis de kermesse
[Rires]
[Musique]
et de nice a bien tenu de l'affluence
beau y siègent toujours dans son école
et il va continuer à siéger le lendemain
et le surlendemain et encore le
surlendemain tous les jours à 10h le
gouvernement démissionne alors les
anglais ont encerclé la ville je n'ai
plus comme principauté d'opérette
même la commission un contrôle s'est
emparé du bateau
pat rigal coltro plus confortable alors
on a cherché de midi est à les installer
ailleurs et on assiste à quelque chose
d'invraisemblable les jours s'écoulent
il ya toujours un gouvernement nazi
parce que des mythes c'est le successeur
désigné par heatley
et alors que dans cette ville il ya
maintenant des centaines des milliers de
soldats de clips nation des journalistes
américains anglais on voit les ministres
se rend tous les jours à 10h valeur
salle de réunion et savez vous quel est
le drapeau qui flotte sur cette salle de
réunion le drapeau à croix gammée
c'est à ne pas croire c'est assis alors
évidemment tous ces hommes sur la proie
des photographes pour les fautes graves
x est une attraction comme un ministre
nazi un drapeau nazi
alors que la capitulation et signé
depuis des jours il ya maintenant vingt
jours de hitler est mort vingt jours et
le gouvernement d'un micro siège tour
mais à quoi sert-il à bague savait où se
réunit on présente des mémorandums aux
alliés sur leur ravitaillement c'est la
circulation sur la possibilité de
reconstruction dans les zones occupées
il délibère il a vu comme ils peuvent
gouvernement et même voici le conseiller
politique d'eisenhower ans berthe murphy
qui vient saluer l'amiral de nice
entrevue qui est mon dieu positive des 2
need et en général britannique vient lui
aussi présenté j'allais dire ces
hommages l'amiral de l'x kite elle est
rentrée le 9 mai de berlin très content
d'ailleurs parce que il dit mais
figurez-vous que mais mes homologues mes
camarades soviétique mentalité à
déjeuner a été superbe
du caviar et du champagne on m'a très
bien traité et ses ministres en en
nourrit quelques espoirs pour l'avenir
une note optimiste
il faut dire que chaque jour vu par le
conseil des ministres s'est un petit peu
plus restreint parce qu'on s'aperçoit
que tel ministre a disparu
il a préféré prendre le large le
lendemain c'est un autre qui disparaît
alors ils sont de moins en moins
nombreux
puis un beau jour on arrête là et elle
ne mâche alcaltel on l'a plus d'avoir
fait massacrer délibérément 50 aviateurs
alliés mais c'est une chose que les
américains n'ont pas envie d'ouvrir et
qu'elle ne sortait rappeler de sa prison
et finira au bout du gant alors on
attend se demande ce qui va se passer
mais vous pensez bien que partout en
europe
cette situation finit par provoquer des
protestations de plus en plus violents
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce
qu'on a gagné la guerre et le drapeau à
croix gammée flotte toujours et quand le
22 mai on vient dire à denis de ce qu'on
l'attend le lendemain avec frites borg
et un autre de ses collaborateurs à bord
du patriat
il dit à ses amis moi si j'ai un conseil
à vous donner cette faire votre valise
et le 23 mai quand ils mentent dans la
matinée à bord du patri gagnait nuée de
journalistes photographes et cinéastes
et dans le bar du bateau le général re
aux anglais lui annonce qu'il est
désormais prisonnier de guerre peu les
hauts commandements décidé de mettre fin
à ses activités gouvernementales pour
l'autoriser à passer chez nuit pour
prendre ses affaires et déjeuner à 13h30
un avion leurs portes vers la prison
qu'est attend qu'il n'en sortira que dix
ans plus tard
quant à l'amiral funk free google
choisit un autre destin il avale une
capsule de cyanure
il est mort plutôt que de choisir la
captivité alors au moment où avait lieu
cette scène est bien le gouvernement
siéger ce qu'il en restait quatre mois
alors la porte a été bousculé tout à
coup des soldats anglais le revolver à
la main qui ont crié haut les mains et
aussitôt ses ministres ont le même
dossier
[Musique]
il n'ya eu de protestation que d'un
schwerin von krause inqiétude le
ministre directeur du gouvernement avec
lequel vous avez négocié lui a dit
taisez vous et comme il avait l'air
maussade un officier rebelle mais
l'équipe smiling garder le sourire mon
mieux et là ils ont vu tout à coup de
vente tous ces photographes tous ces
ignares et ils ont préféré se tourner
vers de métaux lourds et montrer leurs
autres farces aux objectifs
c'est ainsi que dans une scène dérisoire
s'acheva réellement le troisième reich
ce troisième reich dont adolf hitler
avait juré qu'il durerait milan
[Musique]